uh oliver knightis we are here at
sausagefest
uh at commercial center 953 sahara
sweet e8 oliver tell us a little bit
about your restaurant sausage fest for
those who don't know
and tell us how covid has hit
your restaurant really hard well
we started out as a food truck in 2011
and we've grown
to several food trucks now we opened up
the restaurant in 2017.
primarily for use as a commercial
kitchen for our
food trucks and back in march we had to
shut down
obviously with a mandate and we've been
shut down ever since
so once the pandemic hit your business
has been shut down
tell me how things have been here so you
know we've been closed down
since mid-march we are looking to
hopefully
reopen by mid-november but uh primarily
we've just kept it closed
uh we've done some catering out of here
once in a while
oliver you relied heavily on conventions
uh you had food trucks so how have you
been
you know continuing business well we
started up a
a pop-up it's called huli huli grill
and it's a it's a hawaiian themed food
item which
essentially what it is is it's a giant
rotisserie
huli huli means turn turn in hawaiian
so it's uh like a rotisserie for chicken
sometimes people put uh ribs we also do
a roast pork belly
or lechon so how has the community
reacted to this i know we are the ninth
island
uh they've really embraced it you know
we have a strong following
right now uh we do several pop-ups once
in a while
throughout the week um and primarily
we've been using social media
to to get the word out there what have
you learned through this whole
experience with covid
obviously we're still going through
covet um but
you have not been non-stop so what's
your message out there
well you know you have to really look at
your business and see
if there's something that you can modify
with what you
currently have so you don't have to go
out there and you know spend more money
to do a different concept you know
fortunately for us we are mobile so it
was just a
basically an addition to our our
business model
so right now oliver the seats are all up
it is an empty space but
come november you do you are talking
about the possibility of
opening and you also have some future
plans
in the making tell us about those future
goals yeah so uh
you know like i said we are hoping to
open up what we would probably do would
be
a friday saturday sunday maybe uh you
know breakfast brunch
primarily and then what we're still
looking at is pre covered we were
looking at expanding next door
to hopefully open up as a sports bar
raider sports bar and what we would look
to do is
actually have people come hang out with
us at the bar and then we would bust
them over
to the stadium from a commercial center
thank you so much for your time